[Musik]
so wie bergsteigerlegende Reinhold
Messner in Südtirol direkt am Ortler die
JAX im Hof erinnern an seine Abenteuer
im Himalaya der Bergsteiger kämpft seit
langem für einen respektvollen Tourismus
in den Alpen
die schönsten Stellen in Südtirol sind
nicht mehr ansehnlich weil einfach da
hunderte von Leuten täglich sind die nur
die Landschaft fotografieren und landen
glauben damit die Landschaft mitgenommen
zu haben die jungen Leute kommen in die
Alpen aber sie wollten dran haben sie
wollen den Kick haben aber nicht die
nachhaltige Form des Erlebens der Natur
in seinem Messner Mountain Museum zeigt
er uns ihm geht es um Reduktion
fast ohne Hilfsmittel höchste Gipfel
erklimmen
diese Reduktion aus wesentliche
forderten Messner seit langem auch für
den Tourismus in den Alpen ich würde ihn
gerne zwei Dinge aus ihrem Buch vorlesen
rettet die Alpen vor 20 Jahren
geschrieben auf eine weitere
Erschließung der hochgebirgsregion für
das reine Freizeitvergnügen Skifahren
Wandern Biken und klettern muss
verzichtet werden würden sie es heute
noch mal genauso sagen also ich würde
das Wiederholen genauso wir können nicht
weiter einfach jeden Hügel jede Fläche
verbauen weil wir Hotels bauen oder
touristische Infrastrukturen haben weil
früher später diese Landschaft einfach
weg die gibt's nicht mehr kann es sein
dass sich der Tourismus verändern muss
also da normale Tourist dazu uns in die
alten kommt der will in erster Linie
einen präparierten und nicht in Natura
wenn ich bedenke was im Sommer in den
Dolomiten
Straßen dort mit dem besten los ist dann
muss ich sagen das ist einfach zu viel
das ist nicht mehr organisierbar die
Leute bleiben stecken auf dem Autobahnen
sie bleiben Stärken auf den Straßen sie
bleiben stecken auf dem besten die
wichtigen Sachen die wir jetzt zu
bewältigen haben in den alten ist die
Verteilung unserer Gäste also wir haben
an einigen Stellen viel zu viele an
anderen Stellen zu wenige um den
Menschen in den Alpen nicht nur den
Bauern sondern auch den Bewohnern der
alten ein Auskommen zu geben ein
Gleichgewicht zu finden dass man die
Menschen also die Gäste die kommen
aufnimmt und umgekehrt die Landschaft
nicht belastet die ökologischen Fragen
ja sauber löst das ist noch zu machen in
welchen Stellen kann man eben reduzieren
dann kann man verzichten und kann man
sich auch einschränken ohne einen
eingeschränktes Erlebnis zu haben mein
Alpinismus ist der verzichtsalpinismus
bei meiner ersten Expedition hatten wir
neun Tonnen Ausrüstung ich bin acht
Jahre später auf den gleichen Berg
gestiegen erste Begehung also nicht
irgendwas leichtes sondern eine neue
Route erste Begehung und brauchte 60
Kilogramm 9 Tonnen gegen 60 Kilogramm
und damit ist mein Bergsteigen auch
ökologisch sauberer geworden trotzdem
ich musste nach Asien fliegen nach Nepal
weil zu Fuß gehen hätte zu lange
gedauert
was ist also die Alternative zum alpinen
Skizirkus zum Rausch auf zwei Brettern
wie finden die Gäste abseits vom
pistenpanorama wieder ein Gefühl für die
Natur
das Wandern ist die ideale Möglichkeit
sich zu erholen sich
ins Gebirge hinein zu begeben denn nur
in der Geschwindigkeit des Fußgängers
kann ich die Anstrengung verstehen kann
ich den Berg plötzlich einigermaßen
abschätzen wie groß da ist die meisten
Menschen die zu uns kommen im Urlaub die
schauen durch das Autofenster und
glauben diese postkartenberge die kann
man also fünf Minuten besteigen das ist
eben nicht so und sie sind wirklich
gefährlich
[Musik]
ich bin überzeugt davon dass der
Alpentourismus nicht sterben wird im
Gegenteil
er wird sogar noch wachsen wenn wir
Angebote schaffen die nicht auf Kick aus
sind sondern auf Nachhaltigkeit
[Musik]